la réponse courte est ce que c'est la
fin de la croissance et oui si on
regarde en europe ce qui se passe depuis
2007 à peu près partout la production
industrielle est en train de baisser à
peu près partout les constructions sont
en train de baisser à peu près partout
les transports en camions sont en train
de baisser
donc si on regarde un certain nombre de
flux physiques qui font notre économie
ils sont déjà partis à la baisse en
europe depuis 2007
moi je pense qu'on est tout à fait
capable d'atteindre une croissance de 2%
par an de 2 et demi pour cent par an et
pas de raison qu'on n'y arrive pas et
sur une durée longue mais ça requiert de
réformer nos institutions et nos
politiques en profondeur dans un monde
dans lequel s'est essentiellement les
machines qui travaillent à notre place
et les machines manche de l'énergie
c'est l'approvisionnement énergétique
qui fait la croissance est absolument
pas les gens au travail depuis les chocs
pétroliers 74 79
on est en excellent travail et du
chômage partout on est en excès de
capital il ya des bulles spéculatives
partout par contre on a commencé à être
en ralentissement sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique et c'est
ça qui fait que l'économie n'est pas
reparti après les chocs pétroliers et
c'est du reste pour la même raison que
malheureusement je pense que la
prochaine crise n'était ce pas c'est que
de deux à trois ans à partir
d'aujourd'hui comment peut-on donner de
limites à ce qu'on peut découvrir
quand tu la révolution d'électricité on
n'avait pas prévu la révolution de
l'internet
et quand ils leur évolution de la
machine à vapeur on n'avait pas prévu la
révolution d'électricité on veut une
société d'innovation et bien par
définition ce sont des sociétés en
croissance parce qu'elle génèrent de
nouvelles idées je ne crois pas du tout
à la fin de la croissance
je crois qu'au contraire le les
opportunités d'idées nouvelles et
d'interaction intellectuels vont ne vont
faire qu'augmenter au cours du temps
tous les régimes de redistribution les
retraites la sécurité sociale etc toutes
les augmentations à l'ancienneté
tout ce système là lui a besoin de la
croissance pour rester stable et si nous
n'avons plus de croissance on
déstabilise tous ces systèmes et donc il
va y avoir un temps d'ajustement qui lui
va être très compliqué pour un monde
politique qui pour le moment il n'y a
pas réfléchi une demi seconde pour
retrouver la croissance durable il faut
que nous devenions compétitif c'est à
dire qu'il faut qu une vraiment nos
produits qu'on fasse des produits ou pas
cher ou de très bonne qualité pour
satisfaire la demande croissante qui va
venir des pays émergents et ça nous
l'aurons qu'avec des marchés du travail
et des biens et services beaucoup plus
flexible beaucoup plus mobile et bien là
nous serons en mesure de bien alors de
très bonnes perspectives de croissance